c'est pas la bonne personne et vous se
marier non plus toujours pas je suis
sortent du coup je suis sorti en boîte
avec notre ami guillaume ce week end ses
parents et sa femme ellie
type 2
non mais j'adore guillaume est là
l'équipe ensemble nous étions champions
montparnasse ah oui d'accord c'est
immoral terrible c'est la première fois
que je sortais guillaume ça fait
longtemps que j'étais pas de sortie en
boîte il attire les filles comme le pot
dans une ruche c'est incroyable je sais
je n'existais plus toutes les toutes les
filles venaient me vois tu connais ce
grand blond
j'ai vécu le rang le plus mal les ans de
ma vie non jean michel noir a présenté
une amie à lui et moi j'étais un peu
gêné discrètement gg susurrer à
l'oreille de jean-michel jeudi à elle
est mignonne a l'air sympa il allait
avoir directement il a dit hey à mon
pote qui votent déglingué
c'est un témoignage
mais vous si moi j'aime beaucoup le
verbe 1 je connaissais pas ma came vous
quand même j'envie n'a pas changé et
champigny sec à l'âme soeur
ses débuts moore l'humour d'avoir ri
chez nous ils ont en effet ils ont
discuté ce lourd alors et alors vp show
band ou non à les lapider numéro oui ça
non mais c'est pas qui pendait numéro 8
avec lui cet été frère s'y trouve
toujours à la recherche de nouveaux
talents mais est ce qu'il est
super bowl à la
radio
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
brésilienne ami à moi giovanna très
gentil et ces gens panizza
avait été discuté pendant une bonne
partie de la première partie de soirée
et après jour enfin deux comme ça sans
prévenir il l'a quittée pour une autre
comme ça j'étais super laisser les
partis sans me dire au revoir hier à lui
envoyer des messages un peu et ne après
je
battais ont
versé guillaume genton oui
alors moi je m'inscris en faux contre ce
témoignage montre et donc vous être paré
qui seul devant chez eux
vous êtes toujours et que votre 9 oui
j'ai eu bien sûr
le prémur parce qu'il a passé un petit
peu l'été avec moi je vous confirme
qu'il a une masse voilà
non pas tout
bois avec une main exactement 1 voilà
mais je peux te donner un coup qui quand
même
parce que j'ai besoin de partir quand
même dans la deuxième fois
il a feint
pas du tout le cas
je suis jeune et oui bon mec mais ton
couple non il avait accueilli en ami à
moi qui m'a malheureusement qui a bel et
bien qui avait vomi juste avant et du
coup la face
il avait du vomi sur la bouche
le cas
certaines fictions veut redonner ses
diffuser la
réaction
c'est une énorme d'arc à cette histoire
non mais arrêtez sans rigoler c'est quoi
un arrière-goût de
vomissements il a une amie qui était
malade et on en voit là
elle a vomi sous nos yeux oui c'est vrai
mais vous vous avez pris en premier de
nos qualités non mais ça aurait aimé lui
c'est vrai ça beaucoup depuis l'arrivée
des secours y'a rien mais il ya un mec
qui paye
il ya un mec qui donneront théodore mais
c'est tout à la presse qu'elle avait
mangé puisque tu as
qu'elle avait mangé la vraie vie c'est
ce qu'elle avait pu mélanger l'avons mis
à laver manger avant non pas du tout
celles ci ont résonné jusqu'à lyon les
championnats